foreign
I'd love to show enthusiasm but the
problem is this is the world we live in
and I think this what I'm about to show
you should be illegal
take a guess at This Woman's age
can't decide well maybe that's because
she's hiding a trick or two using face
tape
meet Chloe branded online as the world's
best catfish
using tape and elastic Chloe instantly
gives herself a facelift to reduce her
age by up to 20 years
illegal illegal this should be this is
rape it's straight to jail this is race
reception
yeah this is like look I understand look
we all
we all have our little tricks of the
trade you know to try to make things
look a little better you know what I
mean but there is a certain point where
you go now it's illegal now it's
this should be illegal this is wrong
this is ABS it's like that Asian guy
that's suing his wife because she had
plastic surgery never told him and the
kid came out ugly
um
I remember that story guys we live in
Florida if you're in Florida I give you
this advice because it's warm enough
your first state should always be at a
swimming pool party
yep and you make them honestly just any
any place where you have to sit and eat
outside take them to an outdoor concert
yeah because that'll that [__] will
start falling apart fast yeah
that
a drastic Transformations have led to
some unwanted attention online
it's wanted attention it's one you
wouldn't have posted this if you don't
want attention
unwanted attention would be if people
were just you were minding your own
business at a restaurant and people
started screaming at you you're not that
pretty you ugly [__] that's unwanted
attention well she's a woman so the way
it works with them is with white women
they want the good attention
no
it shouldn't be sweet at all and
honestly now that you're looking at her
without without like the filters and
everything even that she doesn't look
that great
I labeled myself as that and I don't
remember saying that but that's really
funny
but despite the negativity Chloe is
determined to create content that
inspires others to lie to hide about
their hide their ugliness oof that's her
that's a rough angle
Chloe decided to keep her real age a
secret and has it revealed to anyone
publicly how old 47.
my guess he really is
well here's my thing I don't care how
old she is because I would never [__]
her it's not about her age it's about
how ugly she is I think you because
they're really the ugly there's some
[__] in their 50s that are still hot
hot yeah so it's not the age this isn't
an ageism thing okay this isn't your
ugly thing which is different than
ageism yes like Sandra Bullock doesn't
have to hide her age no like you know
she's old you still [__] uh Tim b50 uh
got a shirt I already the critical
thought uh no other way my advice to
women don't wear makeup on a first date
yeah but that's because you got big fake
tits critical so you get away with it
um I mean
they're big that wouldn't necessarily
get away with it though